[Música]
faltou foi atravessado por muitas
histórias de pacientes ao longo dos seis
anos de faculdade de medicina
a história que mais me marcou foi o que
ouvi do meu professor de oncologia ea
história da joana
uma mulher que sempre morou no interior
e notou um nódulo um caroço no seio
ela nunca tinha visto aquilo e foi
procurar ajuda da luiza que era vizinha
dela a luís olhou e disse que era muito
simples de resolver
bastava joana passar a própria saliva em
cima do caroço todo dia de manhã é todo
dia de manhã que estará passou um tempo
o caroço cresceu a joana ficou sem
entender e voltou na luiza que disse que
o problema era saliva da joana que não
era boa ea solução era joana todo dia e
na casa da luiza andaluz a passar a
língua dela que era boa em cima do
caroço
depois de um tempo do ritual o que era
um caroço viram a laranja ea luiza
concluiu que o problema era o sangue da
joana que não era bom era fraco e ela
tinha que no posto de saúde de morales
no posto quando ela chegou o médico o
encaminhou até o hospital e quando ela
chegou lá o senhor já cobriu boa parte
da barriga pouco tempo depois a joanna
morreu de um câncer de mama
assim que terminou a história o meu
professor perguntou o porquê da luz até
dito pra passar essa livre em cima do
caroço
ninguém conseguiu achar uma resposta e
ele falou que no interior tem muitos
animais e quando eles tenham a ferida
eles lambem passará
era isso o que a luiza compreendia sobre
tratar doenças
fica bem claro por essa história que se
você não compreende saúde o seu mundo ea
sua capacidade e saudável fica muito
limitada
o nome dessa dificuldade de compreender
saúde é analfabetismo em saúde do inglês
health ele ter sim é comum encontrar
pessoas que acham que tomar um remédio
de oito em oito horas é tomar oito da
manhã e oito da noite
ou que tomar de seis em seis horas é
tomar duas vezes ao dia
a gente pode achar que esse problema
fica só nas classes de baixa renda o que
não é verdade
nos estados unidos que têm melhores
índices educacionais que o brasil um
terço um terço das pessoas é analfabeto
em saúde um grau importante ea maioria
são nativos e brancos
por isso eu prefiro chamar de baixa
compreensão em saúde ao invés de
analfabetismo em saúde no brasil a
situação também é complicada porque 54
milhões de pessoas são analfabetas
funcionais ou seja têm dificuldade de
ler e entender o que leu
é de se imaginar que muitos mais tenham
baixa compreensão em saúde
mas esse dado fica só na imaginação
porque o brasil não estudou esse tema de
forma efetiva apesar da importância que
ele tem na saúde são cinco sinais vitais
pressão temperatura batimento cardíaco
respiração e dom
muitos pesquisadores consideram
entendimento em saúde como sendo o sexto
sinal vital equiparando aos outros cinco
que o que deixa esse assunto ainda mais
importante é que o sistema de saúde é
complicado de usar é difícil navegar
pelo sistema saber onde e entender todas
as informações e formulários
acaba que são dois problemas um é que
muitas pessoas não compreendem bem o
sistema de saúde
o outro é que ele é difícil de ser
compreendido
eu vi esse cartaz nas paredes de um
posto de saúde em cima a gente lê
hanseníase e verminoses e tracoma tem
cura
faz essa lição de casa e proteja se essa
é uma campanha nacional que busca
entrada casos dessas doenças em crianças
mas quem olha esse cartaz pode ficar
confuso do que adianta saber que essas
três doenças tem cura
se você não sabe identificar a opção
hanseníase é uma doença de pele tracoma
é uma inflamação no olho causada por uma
bactéria e que pode levar à cegueira e
verminoses são os velhos que causam
principalmente diarréia a prevenção de
cada uma dessas doenças é diferente
porque juntar tudo isso uma coisa só
e qual é essa lição de casa ser feita
embaixo tem prevenção e saúde também são
matérias das
quem vai ler esse cartaz realmente sabe
o que significa a palavra prevenção é
muita informação e sem propósito
e quando o paciente vai fazer um
tratamento também têm dificuldades
especialmente os que têm doença crônica
que são doenças que não têm cura só
controle ao longo do tempo como pessoas
que têm diabetes ou que tiveram infarto
avc
muitos têm que tomar pelo menos cinco
remédios por dia e fazer as mudanças no
estilo de vida que são parar de fumar e
beber comer de maneira mais saudável
pratica exercício além de fazer exame de
sangue regularmente e caindo no médico
pegar o remédio na farmácia organizar
é muita coisa para aplicar na rotina um
colega médico uma vez falou eu falo tudo
pro meu paciente não tem como ele sair
com alguma dúvida e ele não está errado
é o que nós médicos aprendemos que é o
certo e explicar tudo mas não adianta
explicar tudo de uma vez
muitas vezes parece que o paciente sai
da consulta com uma caixa de jogo cheio
de peças cartas dados e ele tem que
jogar sozinho esse jogo que o objetivo é
ser saudável mas ele só viu as regras
uma vez dentro do consultório e mesmo
que ele saiu do consultório com essas
regras na mão
elas não são simples de entender eu vi
esse material em um consultório médico
onde a gente pode ler as dicas para
controlar os níveis de glicemia não
consumir mel controlar o consumo de
massas incluir fibras fracionar dieta
faça exercícios físicos regularmente são
orientações vagas que não se relacionam
e com linguagem difícil para o
profissional que elaborou esse material
está adequado para o paciente mas o que
acontece é que os profissionais
superestimam o que o paciente consegue
assimilar como mostra alguns estudos
é fundamental que o paciente acredita
ser capaz de fazer um tratamento pra
eles é bem feito e pra ele acreditar
ele tem que saber a resposta de duas
perguntas por que eu tenho que fazer
isso e porque isso é importante saber o
porquê é transformador
o problema é que está difícil de sair
porque como que os profissionais vão
levar em conta o entendimento do
paciente e explicar tudo da melhor
maneira
se não tem o tempo eo aparato pra isso
muitos pacientes a serem atendidos em
pouco tempo até porque não é o
importante são os números
o nosso sistema é organizado pela
quantidade quanto mais pacientes
consultados melhor o rendimento quanto
maior os prédios construídos melhor
saúde meu país vai sair né
o correto na verdade o sistema movido
principalmente pela qualidade quanto
melhor o desempenho do paciente dentro
do que é possível pra ele
melhor saúde que eu faço planos de saúde
em outros países começaram a remunerar
profissionais pelo desempenho que os
pacientes têm porque eu tenho como
avaliar o impacto que o tratamento teve
com exames e sensores
enquanto nosso sistema atual da
quantidade é focado no desempenho do
profissional esse novo da qualidade é
focado no desempenho do paciente da
pessoa e isso causa uma transferência de
poder do profissional para o paciente e
ao mesmo tempo que tudo isso está
acontecendo
as pessoas hoje buscam aquilo que elas
compreendem que elas conseguem se
relacionar
o século 21 é o século da compreensão e
não da informação mas a saúde do nosso
século é muito informativa
acaba que as pessoas não compreendem não
se engajam complicam das suas doenças
perdem dias de trabalho e morrem isso
custa milhões aos serviços público e
privado por ano
a saúde tem que mudar as pessoas não
precisam e nem deveriam se esforçar
tanto para entender e fazer seus
tratamentos
um dos itens a mudar ea receita médica
que é a mesma há mais de 100 anos
quem é que pensa em letra ruim quando se
fala em receita médica
você é algo tão evidente a gente foca o
problema da receita na caligrafia
mas tem outros pontos tão importantes
quanto um deles é que a receita foi
organizada por como paciente deve usar o
medicamento e se pela boca de 12 doze do
12 em 12 horas desde 88 e depois do
almoço na hora de dormir e assim vai
mas quando a pessoa vai tomar os
remédios é organizada por quando ela vai
tomar e não é tão simples de organizar
até porque muitas pessoas estão pelo
menos cinco remédios por dia
outro ponto são os termos
usado nas receitas uso contínuo externo
utópico e podem em breve siglas como vê
o que é via oral
dá para sentir que a receita é feita
pelo médico por um farmacêutico entender
ela não leva em conta o entendimento em
saúde do paciente
foi desse insight que surgiu a
inquietação de criar uma nova receita
centrada no paciente e que seja rápido e
fácil de fazer
o resultado é esse programa de
computador que eu idealizei o
profissional insere os medicamentos de
forma rápida e simples e automaticamente
se baseia na rotina do paciente um novo
modelo de receita médica é gerado esse
novo modelo de receita é organizado em
horários vem com uma linguagem fácil
como tomar pela boca todos os dias e vem
com pictogramas imagens que mostram
quando como e o que tomar pictogramas
nada mais são do que imagens que passa
uma instrução um conceito vários estudos
mostram que eles aumentam a compreensão
do material pelo paciente e alguns até
que aumentam a copa' tomada correto do
medicamento de maneira significativa os
pictogramas e esse formato de receita
foram criados e testados com pacientes
brasileiros assim como o programa foi
com profissionais em um hospital e por
juntar esses pictogramas com essa
mudança de formato esse novo modelo é
até às cinco vezes mais entendível e o
entendimento do que está sendo passado é
a base o primeiro passo para a pessoa se
engajar num tratamento mas engajamento é
uma questão complexa
outros passos têm que ser dados 47% das
pessoas em um estudo disseram preferir
levar o lixo para fora de casa do que
tomar a medicação fazer tratamento todo
dia difícil ainda mais em suporte
contínuo o intervalo de média de uma
consulta ou outra varia de 90 a 180 dias
agora imagina se a saúde for
reorganizada com a tecnologia disponível
hoje e centrada na experiência do
paciente do ser humano e daquele que tem
baixa capacidade de entender saúde o
cuidado seria com
no lado onde eu possa avaliar de perto e
junto com o paciente o que está
acontecendo
o tratamento seria adaptado às
necessidades das necessidades de cada um
com a informação sendo passada de forma
fracionada e simples informação mais
compreensível é aquela que motiva para
uma ação que tem o impacto as pessoas
vão aderir mais e complicar iam e
morreram - as suas doenças
na verdade as pessoas não iriam aderir
mais e complicar iam - elas vão porque
essa é a missão mudar toda a comunicação
eo cuidado em saúde pra dar às pessoas
mais qualidade de vida
mas poder todos têm direito à saúde de
qualidade está lá no artigo 25 da
declaração universal dos direitos
humanos
mas você só tem saúde de qualidade se
você entende o que está sendo dito
deixar saúde mais fácil é garantir um
direito humano básico é uma forma de
empatia
aliás eu quero que a gente leve esse
conceito deixar mais fácil não só para a
saúde mas na empresa no trabalho na
faculdade na vida vamos complicar deixar
de lado o sim constitucionalismo mentes
fala bonito não é falar difícil
rebuscado fala bonito falar na sintonia
de quem está ouvindo eo necessário isso
traz compreensão o limite do seu mundo é
o limite da sua compreensão
hoje a capacidade da sociedade de ser
saudável
a limitada mas só por enquanto
obrigado
[Aplausos]